like bonds are the bonds that hold
together ionic compounds
so basically it's what holds together
cations and anions an example of a
compound that's held together with ionic
bonds is sodium chloride
also known as table salt so here we have
a close-up picture of some really nice
crystals of sodium chloride
and this is something that you could try
at home you can take some
any table salt that you might have
dissolve it up in some water and then
let that water slowly evaporate and if
you're lucky you might get some
beautiful symmetric crystals like these
for me personally at least growing
crystals that look beautiful is one of
the most fun things about chemistry you
can see when we when we look at the
close-up shapes of these crystals that
they have some very beautiful symmetry
that symmetry tells us a little bit
about the structure of these compounds
on a molecular level
if we zoom in on these crystals we can
imagine
actually we don't have to imagine you
can look at these with different kinds
of instruments like x-ray
crystallography and you can look at the
crystal lattice and get information
about how the different ions are
arranged
in these solids so the way that the ions
are arranged determines a lot of things
about the properties of these compounds
so
these ionic bonds
and how the ions arrange tell us a lot
about the solubility of the compound
solubility
and other properties like melting or
boiling points
and it even can be related back to
things like how hard a particular ionic
solid is
so the ionic bonds here in sodium
chloride are the ones that hold together
our sodium ions and our chloride ions so
our sodium plus and our chloride minus
and the strength of an ionic bond is
related to the electrostatic force
the electrostatic force between them
and i'm going to abbreviate
the electrostatic force as f
subscript e
so this is the force between two
charged species
and it's equal to
some constant
k
times the two charges that are
interacting
divided by the distance between the two
charges squared
so here q1 and q2
are the charges and in the case of
sodium chloride for example q1 and q2
would be
q1 might be one plus
from our sodium ion
and q2
might be one minus from our chloride ion
and we could also just switch those two
we could say chloride is q1 and sodium
is q2 and and that wouldn't change what
we get from this equation
and then r2 here
is the distance between the ions and we
usually approximate it as saying it's
the sum
of the ionic radii
for the two ions we're looking at
so we can use coulomb's law here to
explain some properties that are related
to the strengths of ionic bonds
and so the example we're going to go
through today
is going to be that of melting point so
we're going to look at some melting
point trends and try to relate them to
the different variables in coulomb's law
so the first thing we'll look at
the first two compounds we'll compare
are sodium fluoride
and
magnesium oxide
sodium fluoride has a melting point of
993 degrees celsius
and magnesium oxide has a melting point
of
2852 degrees celsius
the other information we know about
these two compounds
if you look up the ionic radii it turns
out that sodium fluoride the distance
between the ions is about the same as
magnesium oxide
they're not exactly the same but they're
pretty close so if we were to say that r
is approximately the same for these two
then we can explain the difference in
melting points using the charges
since melting point is a measure of
basically how much energy do you need to
add to these compounds to break apart
your ions
we would expect melting point to go up
to increase
as f e increases
as the force between the ions increases
we would expect to have to add more
energy to break those ions apart and we
can see that in our first example
magnesium oxide if we look at the
charges on the ions magnesium is two
plus and oxide is two
minus in sodium fluoride sodium is 1
plus and fluoride is 1 minus so we would
expect assuming that r is about the same
q this q 1 times q 2
is 4 times bigger
in magnesium oxide versus sodium
fluoride
so
q1 and q2
product of q1 and q2
is higher
for magnesium oxide and that's why we
would expect the melting point to be
higher
we can also look at sodium
chloride
versus
sodium fluoride
and in this case let's look at well i
don't know maybe this is kind of
artificial the boiling point the melting
point sorry the melting point of sodium
chloride is 800
is
801 degrees celsius
and the melting point of sodium fluoride
is like we said earlier
993 degrees celsius
and so this time the charges are the
same on our ions our q1 and q2 is one
plus for the sodium in both compounds
and one minus for the chloride and the
fluoride
so q1 times q2 didn't change for these
two compounds
but since we changed the anion from
fluoride to chloride
we increased
r here
and increasing r in the denominator
makes
the electrostatic force go down another
way we could put it is that since r
decreases
as we go from sodium chloride to sodium
fluoride
the melting point goes up
so in each of these pairs the compound
that has the higher melting point
is the one that also
has the higher electrostatic forces and
that's either because the charges are
higher q1 and q2 are higher or because
the distance between the ions went down
so these are some examples for how we
can relate the properties of ionic
compounds to the electrostatic force
using coulomb's law
between the cation and the anion